[Musique]
m
et
si je met un support visuel la poudre
noir sombre le côté brûlées sera plus
perceptible
[Musique]
à
et
ils sont avec le scaphandre sur la tête
la taux nul assure tenu donc bien
évidemment ils sont pas d'odeur par
contre ils vont rentrer dans leur module
ont enlevé le sur ce cas font tout où le
plus lourd est là bas en se défaisant
l'odeur la cabine a changé et ça sens
cette poudre noire cramer
[Musique]
m
bien sûr nous ne sommes pas allés sur la
lune nous n'avons pas nous mêmes ici de
véritables poussière lunaire mais nous
avons demandé à nez un parfumeur de
recréer artificiellement cette odeur
d'après les témoignages des astronautes
américains
[Musique]
m